foreign
[Music]
my name is Tyler Morgan wall I'm the
developer of race Shader and the ravers
and in the next 15 minutes I'm going to
tell you how you can turn your 3D data
visualizations into a theme park ride
entirely in r
now before we get started I want you to
think back to the very first theme park
ride or roller coaster you ever went on
I for one very clearly remember my first
roller coaster ride because I was seven
and it was a disaster
it was a bumpy rough wooden coaster that
bruised my ribs and rattled my spine and
every Hill turning bump is still
ingrained in my mind
now I don't have many memories from when
I was seven but that is one of them
now I want you to try to think back to
the First Data visualization you ever
made
it was probably something like this
this or God forbid this
but you probably don't remember the
first state of visualization you ever
put together
and that's because we tend to remember
things in our lives that illicit an
emotional response
my first roller coaster mind a ride
stuck with me because uh of the emotions
it evoked even if they were negative
now you might be thinking well data
visualizations aren't supposed to evoke
emotion they're supposed to be about
informing the reader
and to that I like to make an analogy to
another type of institution that needs
to balance fun and interesting with
informative and educational museums
I like to look at building a data
visualization like a museum curating an
exhibit museums can have a bunch of
self-contained exhibits that are static
small in scope and designed so that
viewers can digest the information at
their own pace much like most data
visualizations
but that doesn't mean museums can't also
build a giant IMAX theater or include a
virtual reality Thrill Ride uh something
that will evoke a feeling of excitement
and patrons long after the information
from the placards has fade from their
faded from their memory so these are two
pictures from the Air and Space Museums
here in DC they have exhibits that both
inform and entertain
and this isn't just conjecture numerous
Studies have shown that the most Vivid
memories tend to be of emotional events
which are recalled with more clarity and
detail than neutral events so while not
every exhibit should be a Thrill Ride
and that doesn't mean none can be
I'm going to show you how you can make
experiences out of your data
visualizations how you can turn a Gigi
plot into a heart-pounding ride
now it doesn't necessarily have to be a
fast-moving roller coaster like this
yours might be more it's a small world
than Space Mountain
but I want you to have this tool in your
skill set and I'm going to show you how
you don't need any fancy 3D modeling
skills or Pixar level animation skills
to make fun 3D rides
so here's what you'll learn in the next
12 minutes
how to make a 3D roller coaster in r
but why you will but also my why you
might want to
um but first I'm going to go over some
basic ways to make 3D plots in r that
don't require any fancy skills and I'll
go over what makes a good 3D databiz
and finally the most common feedback I
get when I give a talk on 3D data
visualization is wow I wish I could make
something like that but I don't work
with any 3D data
so throughout this presentation I'm
going to give a bunch of examples of 3D
data visualizations made from a
different a variety of different data
sets all in our that will hopefully give
you some inspiration to try and make
something of your own
now there are a few packages out there
for 3D data visualization but I'm going
to talk about the ravers the set of
packages I developed that focuses on
making high quality 3D renders with
realistic lighting the main package I'll
be using in this process is Ray render a
package that enables you to make
beautiful pathtrace 3D 3D visualizations
entirely in r
the ray Shader package will be used to
transform your data into 3D models using
either geospatial data or the incredibly
simple 3dgplot interface
and finally I wrote The Ray roller
coaster package specifically for this
talk
it automates the entire roller coaster
construction process down to two
functions one to interactively build
your coaster and another to animate it
so let's cover the basics what exactly
goes into a 3D data visualization
first what kind of data can be used in
3D plots all you need for a 3D database
are data with at least three numeric
components
here we have European flight path data
from the crowdsourced Open Sky Network
flight path data has latitude longitude
and altitude which intuitively
correspond as to to X Y and Z and are
here plotted as 3D paths
this is a fairly straightforward and
intuitive use of 3D but you can also
choose to use 3D Aesthetics with 2D data
much like you might choose a line chart
over a bar chart purely for aesthetic
reasons you might also choose a 3D chart
over its 2D counterpart because you can
make it more interesting and Visually
appealing
this is a map of the submarine fiber
optic cable network and there's no
actual 3D data present just latitude and
longitude data
the cables rise out of the Earth where
they start and fall back in where they
land you could easily plot this as
simple 2D paths on a world map but I
think the floating cables subtle shadows
and rotating Globe really Elevate what
is otherwise a fairly simple data set
into something more relatable and
tangible on a human scale like the Earth
is being wrapped in yarn
so many 3D plots have uh or 2D plots
have direct 3D equivalents but just
replacing points and lines with spheres
and cylinders can lead to mixed results
data floating in the void can be hard to
interpret if we're just presented with a
static image as objects in the
foreground can block those in the
background as we see here in this
rendering of a morphine molecule
generated with the ray molecule package
but you can solve this problem by
animating the 3D data
the movement disambiguates the
foreground from the background so that
the reader can fully interpret the 3D
model
besides points and lines the other main
type of 3D data visualization is the 3D
mesh a continuous grid of data values
this is where the ray Shader package
comes in it takes 2D grids of raster
data and creates 3D models by
transforming the flat Matrix data into
3D so this visualization of the
underwater volcano in Tonga that erupted
earlier this year was generated from a
simple 2D Matrix of bathymetry values
taken from a sonar survey
check out the code to see how
straightforward this is from our Matrix
to 3D model in just a few function calls
now this is true of almost all of the
visualizations you'll see in this talk
the rendering script is usually only a
dozen or so so lines of code most of the
work is in cleaning the data as it poses
so when you're dealing with
non-topographic data the process is
similar you can convert the previously
2D data by extruding it into the third
dimension if you're having trouble
conceptualizing what type of data can be
used for a 3D mesh one rule of thumb is
that any type of data that can be mapped
to the fill or color aesthetic in ggplot
can also be mapped to 3D
uh here we have a plot of infections and
Jon Snow's famous cholera data set where
the points are colored by the near a
number of nearest neighbors for each
infection
the process of converting ggplots to 3D
is fully automated in ratiators plot GG
function and if you want to learn more
information check out my rstudio comp
2020 talk on making 3D ggplots with
rayshader
so one reason you might consider using
3D instead of color is that encoding
data to color requires the viewer to
reference a color bar to understand the
ordering of the data as there's no
intuitive reason why some colors
correspond to lower values and some
colors correspond to higher here I've
plotted the bytes of buildings in
Seattle Washington by mapping the data
to color
height on the other hand intuitively
allows you to judge which values are
less than or greater than others you can
tell when a building here is about half
the height of another by without having
to reference an external color bar
however because 3D introduces ambiguity
in the depth axis you lose Precision
thus 3D data visualizations are great
when the exact numeric values aren't
important but comparing relative values
and getting an overall sense of the
distribution of data is
using both 3D and color can give you the
best of both worlds
color to indicate precise numeric levels
and height to give a more intuitive way
to compare values here we have a
visualization I made of the global
population density using both color and
height the use of color allows the
viewer to map data to direct population
intervals while the use of height
establishes order without needing to
reference a legend
now if you're the type of person like me
that likes to obsess over the tiniest
details of your data Vis good news 3D
brings an entirely new type of detail to
obsess about lighting move over
adjusting ggplot margins
if you've ever talked to a photographer
you know the real secret to amazing
photographs isn't necessarily having the
best equipment but rather having
adequate and well-designed Lighting
if you only have a single light like we
do here in this 3D historical map this
visualization is a bit spooky like a
swing light bulb in a haunted house
if we look at this visualization of the
blooming California poppy fields we see
with multiple distant fill lights we see
the atmosphere has changed completely
much less Moody and much brighter
even easier than all of that is using an
HDR image file for environment-based
lighting which we see here in this
visualization visualization of Monterey
Bay California it lights the scene with
a real world image which results in
natural realistic lighting like your
scene was in that environment
if your data changes over time you can
then also introduce animation to your
dataviz here I used a Microsoft Connect
to capture my movements and load them
into R using the rmo cap package
by extracting the individual time slices
from the movement data and rendering
each frame completely I was able to
combine all the frames into this
animation using the AV package so watch
out Pixar our users are coming for you
you can even use this ability to bring
old friends back from the dead
[Applause]
thank you thank you
so here I've used R and Ray render to
bring Microsoft clippy back to life to
help you debug your data analysis
pipeline
maybe an idea for posits next
professional product
and for the creatively inclined you can
also produce stunning generative art in
3D using Ray render here I've simulated
and plotted the trajectory of a particle
in a strange attractor a type of
differential equation that displays
chaotic motion I've lit the scene with
both a white and red light and change
the material of the object to give it a
glossy Sheen we can also generate
fractal trees using the ray Bonsai
package this is a rewrite of Daniel
Navarro's flame tree package to work in
3D and you can create all different
types of trees when two or three lines
of code all generated in r with nothing
but math
and finally unlike in 2D where there's
only one way to look at a visualization
in 3D you have an infinite number of
camera angles orientations and settings
to choose from it can be intimidating
especially if you've never worked in 3D
before but I've made it a little less
daunting by including a fully
interactive real-time 3D Graphics device
built into array render and working out
of the box with no dependencies for no
weird dependencies
you can fly around your scene with just
your mouse and keyboard and find the
best angle and print out your camera and
info for future use
this is all happening directly in your R
session
you can even interactively save
keyframes and then generate an animation
smoothly flying through your data
visualization or as I'm about to show
you riding through it
now that you know everything you need to
know to make a 3D database an R let's
build a roller coaster
first we need to generate a 3D scene for
our roller coaster to travel through now
this could be any of the visualizations
I've shown up to this point but I'm
going to use a 3D ggplot because ratio
there's 3D ggplot interface is by far
the easiest way to make a slick 3D
database in r
uh this is a density plot of the
diamonds data set in r with the fill
aesthetic mapped to 3D this is one
function called passing the ggplot
object and voila a fully formed 3D
database
you might note that I've turned off
ratiators Ray tracing uh because we're
going to get a much higher quality
version of Ray tracing when we render
the scene with Ray render
now that we have our 3D scene set up
here's where the where the ray roller
coaster package comes in here all we
need to do is call the generate ratiator
coaster function which extracts the
ratiator scene for you and automates the
entire roller coaster construction
process
this function uses ratiators or array
renders built-in interactive Graphics
device to let you fly around the scene
and build a roller coaster directly in R
here I've recorded a video of myself
flying through the scene pressing k at
the key positions I want my roller
coaster to travel through
when I'm done and close the window it
will generate a 3D model of a roller
coaster that travels through those
points
now I've extracted the full 3d scene
here with get ray render scene and used
render scene to get an overhead
isometric view of the ride sort of like
Roller Coaster Tycoon but with less
death and destruction
now that we're happy with our roller
coaster all that's left is simply
calling anime roller coaster with a
movie file name and we get our full
first person animated roller coaster
ride through our data set entirely in
our ta-da
so we're all done creating our roller
coaster
or are we
you see while this is cool you might
note that it's more ride than dataviz
you can't look around because the field
of view here is fixed at 120 degree 120
degrees and the camera view is stuck
along the track
If instead we set the field of view to
360 Degrees we can render the entire
seam at every frame which gives us
something that looks like this
so this is rendering a complete sphere
surrounding the camera at every frame so
that we can see every angle at once this
allows the viewer to choose where to
look
now this animation looks rather funky
and warped
but we aren't going to use the video in
this form
because you can do something very
special with 360 degree videos
by injecting a little metadata to the
mp4 file and uploading to YouTube you
can turn this video into a virtual
reality 3D roller coaster and put
yourself directly inside your database
[Applause]
now the viewer can look and direct their
attention to wherever they want as they
fly along the track because you control
where you look it truly feels like
you're riding a Thrill Ride with
exciting vertigo inducing drops and
dizzying turns that truly leaves an
impression
you don't need any fancy VR gear to
experience this I made this video with
just my phone and a 20 VR head mount and
it only took a dozen or so lines of code
to put together thanks to the power of R
and the ravers
so in summary 3D plotting is an awesome
tool you should consider trying out and
there's no better better ecosystem out
there for uh 3D database than r
thanks the ray renders interactive
renderer and the ray roller coaster
package building an impressive Thrill
Ride Through Your 3D World Is Dead
simple and only takes a few lines of
code
and finally consider combining the tools
of virtual reality with 3D dataviz to
immerse your viewers on rides or tours
throughout your data by actually putting
your viewers in the data visualization
you can form longer lasting connections
to your work by evoking emotion and
allowing the user to experience your
visualization in a more up close and
personal way
thank you so much for your time and
enjoy the ride
[Applause]
[Music]